welcome back to the David packman show I
am Faron cousins sitting in for David
Pacman today if you want more from me
you can find me on YouTube at
youtube.com the ring of fire I also have
my other channel youtube.com
fahrenbalanced and I'm on Twitter
Facebook Instagram and Tick Tock at
farrenbalanced now I want to end in this
last segment with a couple of
interesting stories from throughout the
week that I felt needled a little bit
more exposure now to begin the show
today I talked about the fact that Alvin
Bragg has sued Jim Jordan to stop the
subpoena that he issued against mark
pomeranz now what I didn't mention about
that lawsuit was that contained within
the lawsuit
brag the Manhattan DA's office
outlined the threats the racist threats
that Bragg has received
since the indictments were announced
according to the report the DA's office
received more than one thousand calls
and emails from Trump supporters since
March 18th the day when Trump
inaccurately predicted his own arrest
many of those messages have been quote
overtly racist and anti-Semitic
so I'm gonna read one of them here I'm
going to censor uh some of this stuff
because it's not appropriate
um hey George Soros a whole puppet if
you want president Trump come and get me
remember we are everywhere
and we have guns
another one referred to Alvin Bragg the
first black man ever elected as top
prosecutor in New York called him black
trash
one of them called him AIDS infested
and here's the thing
I have talked repeatedly on my channels
about the fact that it's only a matter
of time before these threats turn into
material action
but it turns out as Bragg revealed
that's already happened let me read this
from Vice
Bragg received an envelope containing
white powder and a specific death threat
against him the letter was immediately
contained to prevent exposure and was
later determined to contain no dangerous
substance according to a letter Bragg
later circulated to his staff
so you had an angry Trump supporter send
a letter saying you know basically I
want you dead
and the letter contained a white powder
the white powder of course was obviously
meant to scare them because luckily this
Trump supporter couldn't get their hands
on anything actually dangerous
that doesn't change the nature of the
threat
they believed at the time it was real
they they almost have to believe that
it's real every time this comes in
and this is what happens this is what I
believe personally Trump wants to happen
that's why he's been out there attacking
Bragg he has called him an animal he has
called him a pervert a lunatic a maniac
those are all words that Trump has used
just in the last week to describe out to
describe Alvin Bragg to describe judge
Merchant
Donald Trump is going after judge
Merchant's family
are these attacks from Trump on these
individuals have to stop and the only
way you can stop that is for judge
Merchant to put a gag order in place
not that I think that would stop Trump
but if you violate the gag order the
judge in the you know issuing has to say
a single violation is a night in jail
I think every time you violate this
every time you send out a tweet that's
an attack on one of these people you're
going to jail for a night
so if you send out a post on Truth
social with three different attacks
that's three nights in jail
that's what the judge could do that's
what the judge should do to protect
these people to protect Alvin Bragg to
protect himself and his family
but the judge had said in the order well
not necessarily in the order but in the
court discussions last week during the
arraignment the judge said look a gag
order is is a far-off thing I don't want
to do it
he urged Trump's lawyers to you know
tone it down to Reign him in and clearly
they failed to do that because I don't
think they want to do it and even if
they wanted to they're dealing with a
client that's not going to listen to
them
so the only possible option here is the
judge to put that gag order in place
people's lives could be at stake
I mean Trump posted the picture of him
with the baseball bat and then Alan
Bragg on the other side of it looking
like he was going to hit him
that's not okay that is violent imagery
that his base sees and they think oh
okay this is what he wants me to do that
is how those people operate
Trump doesn't have to do the damage
Trump doesn't have to be the one out
there getting violent
because he knows that if he just says a
couple of buzzwords to his base shows
them a couple of pictures
they'll take it from there
and I firmly believe personally
that that's got to be what Trump wants
one of our sponsors is betterhelp I am a
huge believer in therapy let's say
you've been thinking for a while about
getting into therapy you know it's the
right move you have things you'd like to
talk to someone about there is no better
time than the present but you don't have
to drive across town every week and sit
in a waiting room because of better help
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists specializing in a wide range
of issues you answer a few questions
about yourself and better help will
match you with a therapist based on your
specific needs and preferences the
sessions can be on the phone video call
chat anytime anywhere from your couch at
home from your office at work and if
your therapist isn't the right fit you
can switch anytime at no charge my
audience gets 10 percent off your first
month at betterhelp.com Pacman the link
is down below